WASHINGTON, D.C., NOW.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER
CARLSON TONIGHT."
THE ADMINISTRATION'S EFFORTS TO
SECURE THE AMERICAN BORDER AND
ENFORCE FEDERAL LAW ARE RUNNING
INTO A SURPRISING GROUP OF
CRITICS.
AMERICAN GOVERNORS, THE ADMIN
ATTRITION WANTS TO EMPLOY UP TO
4,000 NATIONAL GUARD TROOPS ON
THE MEXICAN BORDER TO ASSIST
BORDER PATROL OPERATIONS.
NATIONAL GUARD TROOPS ARE
ORDINARILY UNDER THE CONTROL OF
STATE GOVERNORS.
SOME OF THEM DON'T LIKE IT.
KATE BROWN SAYS IF THE
PRESIDENT ASKS FOR HER GUARD
TROOPS, SHE WILL REFUSE.
STEPHEN BULLOCKS OF THE SAME
THING.
IN NORMAL CIRCUMSTANCES, THE
BEAUTY OF THE MILITARY IS
NATIONAL DEFENSE.
THE DUTY HAS BEEN SACRIFICED ON
THE ALTAR OF POLITICAL GAME.
WE JUST SPOKE TO THE FORMER
GOVERNOR OF MARYLAND.
THANKS FOR JOINING US.
>> THE QUESTION ABOUT
PRECEDENTS, AND 2010,
PRESIDENT OBAMA AUTHORIZED
OPERATION PHALANX WHICH SENT
NATIONAL GUARD TO THE SOUTHWEST
BORDER.
PRESIDENT BUSH TO THE SAME THING
IN 2006.
IF I REMEMBER THE TIME,
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS
THANKED HIM FOR THE HELP.
WHY IS THIS DIFFERENT?
>> THIS IS DIFFERENT FOR A
COUPLE OF REASONS AND IN A WAY,
IT'S NOT DIFFERENT.
HONESTLY WHAT I THINK
PRESIDENT OBAMA LEARNED ABOUT
THE DEPLOYMENT OF NATIONAL GUARD
TROOPS AND THAT REELECTION YEAR
2010 WAS THAT IT WASN'T VERY
EFFECTIVE.
IT WAS VERY EXPENSIVE AND HE
PROBABLY COULD HAVE ACCOMPLISHED
THE SAME BY OTHER MEANS, SO HE
DID NOT WANT TO DO IT AGAIN.
THE QUESTION TO ASK IS IS THIS
REALLY ADDRESSING AN AMERICAN
SECURITY NEED OR IS IT POLITICAL
THEATER?
WHETHER IT'S PRESIDENT BUSH OR
PRESIDENT OBAMA OR NOT
PRESIDENT TRUMP, ANY USE OF
FEDERAL TROOPS IN THE
NATIONAL GUARD TROOPS WITHIN THE
CONTINENTAL UNITED STATES HAS TO
PASS CERTAIN TESTS THAT WE HAVE
PUT INTO NATIONAL LAW THAT
PROHIBITS THE USE OF FEDERAL
TROOPS FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
PURPOSES.
>> Tucker: ENDORSING THAT
DEMOCRATIC GOVERNORS IN OREGON
FOR EXAMPLE AND MONTANA HAVE
DONE A COST ANALYSIS OF THIS AND
THERE AGAINST WASTING FEDERAL
MONEY.
PART OF THEM DIES WHEN THEY SEE
FEDERAL DOLLARS GOING TO WASTE,
THAT'S THE OBJECTION?
>> I HAVE NO IDEA.
I'M NOT SURE WHICH GOVERNORS ARE
SAYING THIS IS A GOOD IDEA AND
WHICH ARE NOT.
ALL I KNOW IS WHEN IT WAS DONE
UNDER PRESIDENT OBAMA IN 2010 IN
HINDSIGHT, I THINK MOST
EVERYBODY AGREED IT WAS A
WASTEFUL USE OF DOLLARS THAT WAS
NOT NECESSARILY.
THERE PROBABLY WILL BE SOME
GOVERNORS WHO MIGHT FIND THAT
THEY ARE VERY SUPPORTIVE IN
USING THEIR OWN NATIONAL GUARD,
THEY WERE IN THEIR STATE TO
SUPPORT FEDERAL PROTECTION OF
THE BORDER.
I'M NOT SAYING IT CAN'T BE DONE,
BUT WHAT I AM SAYING IS THAT
WHEN IT WAS DONE IN THE PAST, IT
WAS FOUND TO BE INEFFECTIVE AND
MANY PEOPLE OBSERVED THAT IT WAS
A STEP OR TWO TO CLOSE TO
VIOLATING THE PRINCIPLES OF THE
ACT WHICH SAYS WE SHOULD NEVER
ALLOW FEDERAL TROOPS UNLESS WE
CAN AVOID IT TO BE USED FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT PURPOSES.
>> Tucker: FROM LITTLE ROCK IN
1957 TO THE UNIVERSITY OF
MISSISSIPPI IN 1961,
WASHINGTON, D.C., AND 1968, 50
YEARS AGO.
FEDERAL TROOPS WERE USED BECAUSE
THERE WAS NO LAW ENFORCEMENT
CRISIS.
>> I SERVED AS THE COCHAIR OF
THE COUNCIL OF GOVERNORS AND
THAT WAS CREATED BY AN ACT OF
CONGRESS TO MEET QUARTERLY WITH
THE SECRETARY OF DEFENSE IN THE
SECRETARY OF HOMELAND SECURITY
TO WORK OUT THESE ISSUES.
THOSE EXAMPLES YOU GIVE ARE
IMPORTANT HISTORIC PRECEDENTS,
ALL HAVE WHICH HAVE TO DO WITH
MAKING SURE WE DON'T USE FEDERAL
TROOPS FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
PURPOSES WITHIN THE
UNITED STATES.
>> Tucker: THEY DON'T WANT ANY
MEANINGFUL STEPS TAKEN TO STOP
IT.
THEY ACKNOWLEDGE IT'S A PROBLEM.
THESE ARE NEW POSITIONS FOR THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
IF YOU'RE HONEST, YOU HAVE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE OF THE VIEWS OF THE
PARTY HAVE CHANGED.
>> YOU'VE FORGOTTEN THAT WHEN
YOU MENTIONED THAT
PRESIDENT OBAMA PROBABLY
DEPORTED.
I DON'T ACCEPT YOUR PREMISE WITH
RESPECT.
BUT THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS IN
FAVOR OF ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION
FLOODING THE COUNTRY WITH DRUGS.
>> Tucker: I THINK YOU'RE
OVERSTATING IT.
I THINK THEY'RE OPPOSED TO ANY
MEANINGFUL ATTEMPTS TO STOMPING
THE INFLOW OF IMMIGRATION INTO
AMERICA AND IT'S VERY HARD FOR
DEMOCRATS RIGHT NOW TO CONCEDE
THAT 11 MILLION ILLEGALS IN YOUR
COUNTRY IS A PROBLEM.
DO YOU THINK IT'S A PROBLEM?
>> I DON'T BELIEVE THE LEVEL OF
IMMIGRATION, EVEN SOME TOTAL --
THAT BORDER CROSSING IN MEXICO
ARE AT ABOUT A 46 YEAR LOW.
>> Tucker: YOU UNVEILED OF
FAKE STATISTIC.
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS ARE UP THREE
TIMES THIS MONTH OVER LAST YEAR.
>> ALL BORDER CROSSINGS ARE DOWN
>> ALL BORDER CROSSINGS ARE DOW
DOWN.
LET'S GIVE DONALD TRUMP VICTORY.
>> Tucker: SETS A DISTRACTION.
11 MILLION ILLEGAL ALIENS AT
LEAST IN THIS COUNTRY RIGHT NOW.
>> WE NEED TO DO SOME THING
ABOUT IT.
>> Tucker: ANYTHING SHORT OF
GIVING CITIZENSHIP AND VOTING
RIGHTS AND SENDING THEM HOME,
WITHOUT BE ACCEPTABLE TO YOU?
>> I THINK SOME OF THEM SHOULD
BE HOME, BUT THE VAST MAJORITY
OF THEM PROBABLY SHOULD NOT BE.
THEY SHOULD BE GIVEN A PATHWAY
TO CITIZENSHIP AND WE SHOULD
ENGAGE AND COMPREHENSIVE REFORM
AS WE HAVE.
>> Tucker: 11 MILLION IS A
LOT, WHAT PERCENTAGE DO YOU
THINK?
>> CERTAINLY ANYBODY WHO'S A
SERIOUS THREAT TO PUBLIC SAFETY,
THEY SHOULD BE RETURNED AND
DEPORTED AND THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE
BEEN DOING AS A COUNTRY FOR SOME
TIME.
I THINK THE VAST MAJORITY OF